and uh I couldn't bring my my polarized
sunglasses here so I brought these
actual polarizers here so they if you
take this and put in front of your
telescope there
you have now made a polarimeter you have
made a polarization sensitive telescope
now you may not be able to immediately
know how you would use such a thing but
one way to think about it now take this
guy and look at a light look at a light
source put one up to your eye and now
put the other one in front of it
anywhere and now rotate them
what happens to the light source
becomes brighter and dimmer and brighter
and dimmer yeah so that's called a
quadripolar pattern right so it's
repeating it goes bright dim bright dim
uh it rotates twice in intensity for
every single physical rotation wow and
that's because of the property of the
photon the photon is a spin one field
but the polarization of light is it's
the axis at which its electric field is
oscillating its electric field is
marching straight up and straight down
and so therefore vertical polarization
is the same as negative vertical of
polarization and so you get the same
pattern as you rotate two times for
every one physical rotation is this like
a spin a spin two object so now if you
put that in front of the telescope
you can do one of two things now you're
polarizing all the light that's going in
because you have one of the polarizers
and then you can analyze it as you
rotate the other one you can analyze it
and change the amount of polarization
or you can put this kind of very special
crystal in here there's a crystal it's
called calcite this is from Lex Luthor
not Lex Friedman this Crystal put it on
top of your printed notes there and tell
me what does it look like
there's uh
like I could see everything twice it's a
double image it's a double image that is
a special Crystal that has two different
indices of refraction so light emerging
which is unpolarized from the Black Ink
comes out and it splits into two
different directions and it could split
even more if I made the crystal give you
my more expensive Crystal but that's all
I have what is the crystal with this
kind of property called it's called
calcite this is Crystal it's called
birefringent Crystal bi means two
refringent means refracting so this is a
special type of material that separates
light based on its polarization it's
pretty clean
Buy Signal yeah it's it's cleanly too
yeah I'm seeing two very cleanly it's
very Crest right so that's that's yours
to keep with every time you host me now
take the polarizer underneath your left
hand uh yeah put it on top of the
crystal
and kind of move it back and forth wow
this is incredible you can switch as you
rotate you switch from one
uh signal to the other so it's one of
the refractions to the other
whoa so that is now you are analyzing
the polarization you're confirming the
light comes out of the crystal two
different types of polarization and
effectively what we do is we have those
two things if you like but working in
the microwave so our detector what's
where this the cosmic photons are
brightest in the microwave regime and
the electromagnetic spectrum and we're
coupling that to a refracting telescope
but your eyes are refracting telescopes
so you are a polarimeter right now the
human eye can actually slightly detect
polarization
um but otherwise it mainly detects its
intensity of light and the color that's
what we call color and intensity
brightness so you're devising a
instrument that's very precisely
measuring that pool exactly and doing so
in the microwave region with detectors
not made of biological human eyes retina
cells but of superconductors and uh
things called belometers and and this
has to be done at temperatures close to
absolute zero under vacuum conditions
one billionth of the pressure we feel
here at sea level